uh why don't we go instead to evan from
is it pronounced harrogate
it's uh harrogate david harrogate
welcome sir
thank you very much um i had a question
just about um kind of argentine public
opinion on the fault and that's okay
sure it's kind of a three-part question
um because i'm kind of i don't really
know how to get the republicans or
government opinion on the issue so i was
just kind of wondering do you know what
the kind of public opinion and what the
government think is um what is your
opinion and
uh it might not be analogous but do you
think there's any kind of
uh taiwan type analogy to it at this
point or not i don't think that with the
falklands there's much of a taiwan
analogy at least that i would be uh able
to articulate but uh this is this is a
good question it's the
uh it's the 40-year anniversary of the
falklands war
the falklands are these islands off the
coast of argentina and i am from
argentina and i know that people may
expect me to have some particular hot
take or maybe even a biased view because
i'm from argentina i mean listen the uh
my understanding of public opinion in
argentina is that most argentinians
believe that the falklands should be
argentinian
um my view is that that that's not at
all clear to me um if i if you look at
the the history i don't know the full
history of the falklands but you can
definitely find periods
in the hundreds of years ago where
different populations were there to say
who controlled it i just am not enough
of a student of it to say
uh but to me
yeah go ahead
i think i think it was french originally
and then it was kind of uh abandoned for
a while and then it was kind of flicked
between spanish and majority british
yeah and so listen for me the you know
sometimes you'll see argentinian soccer
matches and people unveil flags that say
the falkland islands are argentinian and
stuff like that
for me it's an unusual hill to to look
to die on i recently saw because of the
anniversary on argentinian news they
brought like three veterans
from that three argentinian veterans and
the framing of the entire segment was
like obviously the islands are
argentinian when it's like not at all
clear from history that that's the case
and i know that people on both sides
will make very strong arguments i think
it's politically ambiguous at best
i think because one of my friends works
in the industry out there i think if you
have the full and stamp on your passport
you're not allowed to go to argentina
that may be the case that's similar
that's similar to if that's the case
that's similar to there are there are
middle eastern countries where if you've
been to israel you're not allowed to go
in that that reminds me of that there's
one other historical note i would
mention
at the time
in uh at the time 40 years ago when this
war took place
uh it was very stupid to think that
argentina was going to be able to beat
the uk in a war like obviously that
wasn't going to happen and there was a
very cynical nature with which there was
propaganda value to appearing or
attempting to fight this war because of
what was going on in argentina at the
time starting to get out of this uh you
know military dictatorship government
and this type of thing and so
a lot of people would look at it and say
it seemed really stupid to think that
argentina's military could fight the
uk's and it was and the reason was it
had propaganda value to some degree
all right okay
cool oh yeah thank you very much all
right thank you so much for the call
yeah good i i was i figured at some
point someone would ask about that
because of the because of the timing and
someone did